under secretory is a thousand
generations live in Nina
this is your fight
[Music]
starwars the rise of Skywalker at a
pg-13 get tickets now it's too dangerous
I need to go alone we're all in this to
the end
we've got friends out there
good people will fight if we leave them
they've taken enough of us now we take
the war to them
let the final battle
begin star wars the rise of Skywalker
video pg-13 get tickets now
let the final battle begin
we won't surrender we make our last
stand
starwars the rise of Skywalker get
tickets now
please pass town all we know the
thousand generations live in you now but
this is your side
I'm December 20th
this saga
we'll end let us final battle
again
starwars the rise of skywalker get
tickets now
they find out
confronting fear
the destiny of a Jedi
your destiny
[Music]
it's okay that we're here it's okay that
you're here's good to see you that to us
starwars the rise of Skywalker get
tickets now
this will be the final word
in the story of Skywalker
[Music]
[Music]
starwars the rise of skywalker get
tickets now
you